so now we have a simple service wasn't
that easy
but it still doesn't wake itself up
fortunately there's a system service for
that
this is a good opportunity to introduce
the alarm manager the alarm manager
allows you to tell the system that you
wanted to wake a component of your
application up after a period of time
and do some processing in the background
you can even have it wake up your
application periodically but what do we
wake up in the background
that would be an android component we
haven't seen before called a broadcast
receiver a broadcast receiver is a
special class that is used to receive
intent broadcasts often from other
applications typically a broadcast
receiver will register an intent filter
for these broadcasts
it's also one way the application will
listen in on alarms alarms take
advantage of a new kind of intent called
a pending intent a pending intent is a
special kind of intent that is handed
from one application to another the big
difference between a pending intent and
a regular intent is that a pending
intent gives permission for the app
using it to send data with the same
permissions and application identity as
the app that created it in android this
allows a system process to call your
application back in a specific
asynchronous way without compromising
the android security model in alarms a
pending intent is used by the alarm
manager to talk to the broadcast
receiver we create
let's add some alarm stuff first i'm
going to add a broadcast receiver as a
static inner class of sunshine service
since this is an android component i'll
register this broadcast receiver in the
manifest
note the way a static inner class is
notated
okay i've given you the bones of a
broadcast receiver that can handle an
alarm but now it's your turn
you can create a pending intent from an
explicit intent to have the alarm
manager activate your broadcast receiver
i recommend setting the alarm to
something absurdly short like five
seconds so you can easily test that it's
working